the world at large is currently
experiencing what could be called
wyatt wrestlemania a russell songs if
you will
get it the actor made big waves in
smaller circles at the start of his
career steadily gaining momentum and
critical attention with roles like sam
in at the devil's door
charlie willoughby and everybody wants
some ezra o'keefe in ingrid goes west
corporal lewis ford in overlord and sean
dud dudley in lodge 49
now the young actor has captivated
audiences on a global scale
through his role as the increasingly
unhinged new captain america
john walker in the disney plus marvel
series the falcon and the winter soldier
fans worldwide have praised russell's
acting chops with
many stating that he's the best actor in
the series
and in the marvel cinematic universe as
a whole
with that in mind it's little surprise
that there's been a ton of chatter about
what russell's next move will be
marvel actors get a unique kind of
exposure that few other actors
experience
elsewhere and if the world wasn't
already russell's oyster pre-mcu
it certainly is now russell does have
one film slated for release in 2021
the psychological thriller slash novel
adaptation the woman in the window in
which he plays david winters
but what project might he take on from
there
well we know at least one that he won't
go near the reboot of escape from new
york the 1981 sci-fi
action classic that starred none other
than russell's own dad
kurt russell even though he seems like
the most logical choice to replace his
father in the escape from new york
reboot
they do look a lot alike and there's no
better source for inspiration than your
dad who actually played the character
before
wyatt russell has a totally valid reason
for not wanting to do so
the reboot of the classic 80s movie has
been in the works since 2020 but
no one has stepped up to take on kurt
russell's iconic role of snake pliskin
just yet in a february 2020 interview
with joe blow
the invisible man writer and director
lee winnell who's attached to write the
reboot
said casting the younger russell in the
role of snake would be
the obvious thing to win the fans over
but now in april 2021
wyatt russell has gotten candid about
why he won't be stepping into his dad's
old combat boots
during an interview with esquire the
topic of the escape from new york reboot
came up
and the falcon and the winter soldier
actor shared his thoughts on the project
he said there will be no snake reboot
from me
that's like career suicide 101 that's
like
what not to do i don't know if anybody
else could be snake pliskin
good luck go get him i sincerely wish
you the best of luck
i just don't know how it's possible and
for me if i really wanted to get people
sending me hate mail
i think that's what i should do i will
not be ever
doing anything like that rebooting a
beloved movie is always a dicey prospect
and more often than not it seems to go
wrong so it only makes sense that wyatt
russell would want to stay
far away from the escape from new york
remake it likely doesn't help that he
would be opening the door to comparisons
to his dad's performance
too and though any actor who takes on
the role of snake will inevitably face
criticism
it would be extra hard for russell since
he's worked so hard to establish his own
career in hollywood
beyond his famous father's shadow wyatt
russell
isn't the only person in hollywood with
reservations about the escape from new
york reboot
lee wannell is also uncertain about how
to approach the story and he's the one
who's been tasked with writing it
shortly after it was announced that he
would be penning the reboot winnell
revealed he had
no idea how to approach such a beloved
property
when all told io9 i'm a big fan of
escape from new york and i'm afraid of
it in a way that i wasn't with the
invisible man
i feel like the invisible man has such a
long and storied history with so many
people attacking the character from
different angles that it gives you
permission to mess with it a bit
not so with escape from new york it is
very much the product of one brain
and how are you going to replace kurt
russell
so i think i'm a little afraid of it and
i want to approach it
very carefully it seems the solution to
the problem is simple
bring back kurt russell for the new
escape from new york movie
sure he's 70 now and he claims he's
ready for retirement
but even his son knows there's only one
snake pliskin
and it's impossible to picture an escape
from new york reboot without him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
all the russell's are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell
so you don't miss a single one